how important is it to you as an athlete
that scientists sport products are
informed choice approved it is so
important initially we were told no
supplements the only way you can
actually guarantee that you're going to
be safe and clean is to have bread and
water as they say but to know that
there's the added assurance that
anything we do have from the science and
sport range has been tested gives you
the peace of mind and a guarantee that
you can be performing and none of your
performances are the question
[Music]
it's not questionable for us they have
to be able bidden actually consider
using them at all so yeah I think that's
that's a massive positive for science in
sport we confident the product is 100%
clean and we can have faith in knowing
that it's safe to use because there's
nothing worse than having an accidental
positive test
we know that the products are you know
triple batch tests and also the products
are based on scientific evidence they
have a range of products that truly work
there's a couple of countries that we've
traveled to where we're actually not
allowed to eat the meat if there's a
risk of contamination so often we are
having additional protein bars and
protein shakes after dinner because
we're not getting the protein in our
diet in those countries it's the number
one factor that we look at when we're
talking about nutrition is like okay is
it tested first is a batch tested does
it have that inform sport for any so
yeah it's critical
[Music]
you